สวัสดีค่ะครูชี้สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะทุกๆคนค่ะ
ขอต้อนรับนะคะทุกๆคนสู่ห้องเรียนภาษาไทย
ห้องเรียนคัมภีร์ไบเบิ้ลไทยค่ะ
แล้วก็ในวันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครูชิก็มา
พบกับทุกคนนะคะในวันนี้วันอะไรครับครูชิ
วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะ
วันพฤหัสบดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 21
ค่ะ
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนกันยายนค่ะ
ปีพุทธศักราชหรือว่าพ.ศเท่าไหร่คะ
พุทธศักราช
ค.ศหรือค.ศเท่าไหร่คะ
คริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะ
วันนี้เราก็มาเจอกันอีกแล้วนะ
คะในวันพฤหัสบดีวันที่ 21 เดือนกันยายน
เป็นเดือนที่ 9 นะคะนะพุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสต์ศักราช
2023 ค่ะ
วันนี้เนี่ยคลุกชี้เนี่ยเห็นครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
เป็นกูรูหรือผู้รู้มีความรู้
เป็นกูรูเลยหรอคะ
เป็นผู้รู้เพราะกูที่เห็นครูปุ๊กเนี่ย
เลี้ยงแมวแมวแมว
3 ตัว
เห็นไหมข้างหลังครูปุ๊กก็เป็นรูปแมว
แสดงว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยรักแมว
ชอบแมว
ให้ค่ะ
แมวด้วยจริงๆครูก็ชอบสัตว์หลายๆชนิดหลายๆ
อย่างเนาะนะแต่ที่บ้านเนี่ยมีสัตว์เลี้ยง
เนี่ยเป็นแมวค่ะ 3 ตัวอย่างที่ครูชี้บอก
ค่ะ
แล้วแมวที่บ้านเนี่ย 3 ตัวเคยว้าวๆๆๆๆเคย
ทะเลาะกันเนี่ย
โอ้โห
บ่อยๆค่ะตอนนี้ก็ยังทะเลาะกันค่ะ
นะ
ก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันว่าทำไมทำไมนะแมวตัวที่
1 เนี่ย
มันหวงที่ไง
มันเหมือนเป็นเจ้าของบ้านฉันอยู่บ้านนี้
ตัวเดียวใช่ไหมตัวแรก
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยมาตัวที่ 1 เลยใช่ไหมมาตัว
แรกเลยก็เลยคิดว่าเมื่อก่อนที่นี่เนี่ย
เป็นบ้านของฉัน
ถูกต้องแล้วค่ะนะแล้ว
พอครูปุ๊กก็เห็นว่า
ลูกสาวเนี่ยรักแมวมากๆใช่ไหม
ก็กลัวว่าถ้า 1 วันแมวตายเนี่ย
นะเขาน่าจะเสียใจมากๆเพราะว่าแมวเนี่ยมัน
แก่แล้ว
อ้อ
ครูปุ๊กก็เลยไปเอาแมวไปขอไปขอแมว
นะมา 1 ตัว
แล้วก็เลยเอามาตอนนั้นเนี่ยอายุแมวที่เอา
มาเนี่ยประมาณซัก 6 เดือน
พ่อก็ยังตัวเล็กๆ
ใช่
ใช่เพราะว่าแมวตัวที่ 1 ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยชื่อ
น้ำตาล
แต่น้ำตาลเนี่ยเป็นตัวเมียเป็นผู้หญิง
แล้วตัวเมียสัตว์เราจะเรียกเป็นตัวเมีย
ตัวผู้ตัวเมียก็คือผู้หญิงตัวผู้ก็คือผู้
ชายแต่ห้ามใช้กับคนนะคะไม่ต้องบอกครูปุ๊ก
เป็นตัวเมียเนี่ยไม่ใช่นะคะห้ามเลยคนไทย
จะโกรธ
ครูปุ๊กเป็นผู้หญิง
สบายใจตัวเมียตัวผู้เอาไว้ใช้กับสัตว์ใช่
ไหมใช่ค่ะนะก็ครูปุ๊กก็เห็นว่าแมวตัวแรก
ชื่อน้ำตาลเนี่ยเป็นตัวเมีย
นะแล้วมันก็เคยมีลูก
แล้วลูกมันตาย
ใช่ไหม
เราหามาหาแมวอีกตัวนึงมาเป็นเพื่อนก็เลย
ไปเอาแมวเด็กๆมา
ครูคะครูปุ๊กถามน้ำตาลหรือยังคะ
น้ำตาล
น้ำตาลอยากมีลูกไหมเดี๋ยวไปเอาเอาลูกแมว
มาให้เลี้ยงนะเอออยู่ด้วยกันนะถามถามน้ำ
ตาลหรือยังคะไม่ได้ถามค่ะ
คิดเองเข้าใจแมวไงคิดว่ามันต้องอยากมี
เพื่อน
เข้าใจครูปุ๊กแล้ว
คนเราเนี่ยชอบคิดเองโดยไม่ได้คิดว่าเขา
เป็นแมวแต่คิดว่าเขาเหมือนเหมือนเรา
มีเพื่อนค่ะ
เหมือนที่บ้านค่ะ
มีคนที่แบบรักสัตว์แล้วก็คิดเอาเองเหมือน
กัน
ที่บ้านกูชิเลี้ยงหมาค่ะแล้วที่บ้านก็คิด
ว่าอ๋อ
ถ้าเอาข้าวเนี่ยแล้วก็มีหมูปิ้งใช่ไหมกับ
ข้าวเนี่ย
หมาอาจจะไม่อร่อยค่ะเพราะมันไม่เค็มเพราะ
ว่าคนเลี้ยงเนี่ยชอบเค็มคนเลี้ยงต้องใส่
น้ำปลาแล้วก็คลุกข้าวให้หมา
เพราะว่าคิดว่าหมาเนี่ยชอบเค็มด้วยบางที
ต้องมีไก่ใช่ไหมแล้วก็ใส่หม้อแล้วก็มีน้ำ
เอ้ยมันจืดเค้าก็เลยใส่เกลือค่ะเค็มๆลงไป
แล้วก็ชิม
[เพลง]
คิดว่าอร่อยนะ
น่าจะเหมือนเฟรนฟรายไงถ้าไม่ใส่เกลือไม่
อร่อยซูชิ
เองแต่ไม่ได้คิดจากการที่ดูแมวหรือดูหมา
ไงแต่คิดแล้วก็คิดว่าถ้าเป็นฉันเนี่ยฉัน
ชอบแบบนี้แมวก็ต้องชอบแบบนี้หมาก็ต้องชอบ
แบบนี้
ครูปุ๊กไม่ได้ถามไม่ถามแมวแต่ครูปุ๊กคิด
ถึงลูก
เพราะว่ากูคิดว่าลูกสาวเนี่ยรักแมวมากๆ
ใช่ไหมนะแล้วถ้าแมวตายเนี่ยเพราะว่ามัน
อายุมากแล้วใช่ไหมก็เลยคิดว่าถ้า
แมวตายเนี่ยลูกเสียใจแต่ถ้ามีอีกตัวนึง
เป็น 2 ตัวเนี่ยตัวนึงตายอีกตัวนึงก็ยัง
มีอยู่ไง
ก็ลูกอาจจะเสียใจแต่ไม่มาก
ก็เลยไปขอแมวมา 1 ตัวเป็นตัวผู้
เพราะว่ามีเมียมีตัวผู้มันน่าจะอยู่ด้วย
กันได้
มันอาจจะ
ปิ๊งๆกันได้ด้วย
มันอาจจะแต่งได้
ครูก็เลยไปเอามาขอมานะเสร็จแล้วพอมาอยู่
บ้านโอ้โหพอปล่อยปุ๊บน้ำตาลเนี่ยโกรธมาก
ฉันเนี่ยเป็นมาเฟียอยู่ที่นี่นะ
เป็นเจ้าของบ้านนะเธอเป็นใคร
แล้วมันก็เลยจะตัดไง
เด็กๆก็กลัวใช่ไหม
บางทีหนูก็เลยต้องเอาแบบใส่มีตะกร้าที่
มันมันเป็นรูๆๆเนี่ยนะเอาแมวตัวเล็กใส่
แล้วก็ปิดนะแล้วก็ไปวางไว้ให้น้ำตาลเนี่ย
เห็นมันก็
แง้วๆๆก็โอเคให้มันใกล้กัน
ค่อยๆให้เขาทำความรู้จักกัน
เออใช่แต่
น้ำตาลไม่โอเค
อันนี้เขาบอกว่ามากๆเนี่ยคนที่เลี้ยงแมว
เนี่ยก็เข้าใจตามความคิดของเราไง
จริงๆแล้วเนี่ย
ไปอ่านเรื่องแมวไงแล้วครูชิก็บอกว่าแมว
เนี่ยค่ะบางทีคนน่ะชอบเอาแมวมาอุ้มใช่ไหม
มากอดแล้วก็แบบ
แล้วดูหน้าแมวดิ
เบื่อ
อีกแล้ว
จับฉันมาอีกแล้ว
ทำไม
แบบเฮ้ย
เบื่อจริงๆ
ดูหน้าแบบเบื่อมากใช่ไหมเหมือนกัน
อันนี้ไม่ไม่ใช่ว่าแมวชอบค่ะแต่ว่าคนนี้
แหละชอบ
อยากกอดอยากฟัดฟัดก็คือเหมือนกับขยำให้
มันแบบอื้อหือมันเคี่ยว
อื้อ
เค้าเลยบอกไงแมวเนี่ยนิสัยของแมวเนี่ยมัน
อยู่ตัวเดียวได้มันชอบอยู่ตัวเดียว
มันไม่ชอบมันไม่เหมือนหมาที่แบบมีเพื่อน
เยอะๆสนุกๆไม่เหมือนคน
ที่แบบชอบมีเพื่อนเยอะสนุกได้อะไรอย่าง
นี้นะแต่แมวเนี่ยบางทีเนี่ยเราอาจจะเห็น
แมวเนี่ยชอบแบบนั่งแล้วก็มองไปที่
หน้าต่างใช่ไหมมองวิวแล้วก็มองไปข้างนอก
ทำตาม
ปิ้งๆเลยนะ
[เพลง]
ก็คือตาที่มันเล็กลงอ่ะค่ะ
แต่คนเราเนี่ยพอเห็นแมวอยู่ตัวเดียว
ชะเง้อมองข้างนอกมองไปมองมาโอ้ยสงสัยมัน
เหงา
อยู่ตัวเดียวมันเหงา
มันน่าจะมีเพื่อนนะมันจะได้ไม่เหงา
อันนี้ก็คิดเองใช่ไหม
ใช่แต่ว่าแมวบางตัวทำได้บางตัวเนี่ยมัน
ไม่ชอบค่ะมันไม่ชอบเลยมันอยากเป็นตัว
เดียวในบ้าน
มันรู้สึกว่าไม่ชอบมีอะไรมายุ่งยากกับมัน
เพราะฉะนั้นเวลาเจ้าของอ่ะไม่อยู่บ้านน่ะ
เจ้าของออกไปข้างนอกก็โอ๊ยอยู่ตัวเดียวจะ
อยู่ได้ไหมเนี่ย
ไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวฉันเอาไป
โรงพยาบาลด้วย
เพราะว่าโรงพยาบาลเนี่ยนะสำหรับสัตว์
เนี่ยตอนนี้เขาก็มีรับเลี้ยงรับเลี้ยง
เนาะ
หรือว่าเป็นโรงแรม
5 ดาวเลยนะเพราะว่าเป็นโรงแรมสระก็คือ
เวลาคนไม่อยู่บ้านแล้วก็จะเอาแมวไปฝากให้
เลี้ยงมันต้องบางตัวเนี่ยมีเวลาป้อนยามี
เวลาให้อาหารนะมีเวลาทำความสะอาดอาบน้ำ
เปิดแอร์ให้ด้วยค่ะฮึๆๆ
ใช่ค่ะ
นะก็เลยต้องไปฝากไว้ที่โรงแรมค่ะ
แต่เขาบอกนะคะว่าคนที่เขาทำทำงานที่ดูแมว
อ่ะ
ทำวิจัยทำรีเสิร์ตเนี่ยเขาบอกว่าแมวมัน
เป็นสัตว์ที่อยู่ตัวเดียวได้เพราะงั้น
ปล่อยมันอยู่บ้านตัวเดียวเนี่ยมันอาจจะมี
ความสุข Yes วันนี้บ้านเป็นของฉัน
เราก็คิดว่าคือเราเห็นมันชอบเหงาๆไงเราก็
เลยคิดว่ามันแบบเออมันอยู่ตัวเดียวมัน
อยากจะมีเพื่อน
หรืออีกอย่างนึงค่ะครูปุ๊กแมวเนี่ยชอบไป
จับหนูจับจิ้งจกอ่ะแล้วก็เอามาให้เอามา
ให้ถูกคุกที่บ้านมีไหมคะที่บ้านเป็นไหม
เป็นค่ะ
มีตัวมันมีตอนนี้มีตอนนี้มี 3 ตัวเนาะ
ใช่ไหมมี 1 ตัวเนี่ย
ชอบมากชอบแบบมันจะเหมือนแมวเด็กตลอดเวลา
ชอบเล่นชอบสนุกชอบจับนู่นจับนี่มาเนาะแต่
เก่งมากนะจับหนูก็ได้ค่ะ
อืม
เออ
แล้วก็ไปจับหนูมานะไปเอาหนูมาจากไหนก็ไม่
รู้แล้วก็เอามาในบ้านค่ะ
อันเนี้ยเขาบอกมันเป็นนิสัยของมันค่ะ
แมวเนี่ยเหมือนเหมือนเสือ
เห็นสัตว์อะไรที่วิ่งๆแล้วแบบคือไม่ใช่
หิวนะคะ
แต่สนุกสนุกที่คอยแบบแล้วก็
นึกถึง Tom  and  Jerry นะ
วันนี้ฉันจับเธอได้แต่ไม่ได้คิดจะกินนะ
สนุก
ใช่ๆกูชิเขาจับจับหนูมาปุ๊บเอามาเล่นเล่น
ๆบางทีก็กัดแล้วก็เหวี่ยงปิ้ว
เสร็จแล้วก็ตามไปแล้วก็ตบๆๆแล้วให้เป็น
ให้มันเดินเพราะมันไม่เดินตบๆๆ
ถ้าไม่เดินเนี่ยนานๆแล้วเนี่ยก็จะเบื่อ
ไม่อยากเล่นแล้วไม่สนุก
หนูมันก็เลยฉลาดไงมันรู้ว่าถ้าเกิดแมวตบๆ
ๆแล้วมันไม่วิ่งเนี่ย
แมวไม่สนุกและแนวแบบไม่สนุกละเพราะว่า
สนุกเมื่อเวลามันวิ่งใช่ไหมแล้วก็จับเขา
บอกว่าตอนที่แมวจัดหนูหรืออะไรเนี่ยเขา
บอกว่า
สมองมันเนี่ยมันจะหลั่งความสุข
เอ็นโดรฟินเหรอคะ
มันทำให้มันติดใจไงติดใจที่จะเล่นล่า
เหยื่อลากก็คือตามหาตัวไหนที่วิ่งๆๆเนี่ย
แต่ไม่ได้หิวเพราะว่ากินอาหารอิ่มแล้ว
แต่ยังสนุกที่จะไปจับเล่นๆใช่ๆเพราะว่า
แมวครูปุ๊กเนี่ยก็ไปจับหนูจับนกจับนกได้
ด้วยค่ะ
อันนี้เขาต้องยิ่งมาโชว์ค่ะครูปุ๊ก
ฉันจับนกได้ขนาดนกบินได้เนี่ยฉันยังจับมา
ได้เลยแสดงว่าฉันยังแบบเดินเบามาก
แต่กูชี้เนี่ยเคยเห็นในคลิปวีดีโอนะ
เวลาที่เขาจับหนูอ่ะแมวจับหนูอ่ะแล้วแมว
ก็จะเล่นใช่ไหมเพราะหนูวิ่งแมวก็จะวิ่งไป
ไล่แล้วก็มาเล่นแบบที่ครูปุ๊กบอกนะคะหนู
ก็เลยแกล้งตาย
มีหนูแกล้งตายหนูก็ฉลาดนะหนูมันก็ฉลาดมัน
รู้ว่าถ้าเมื่อไหร่มันอยู่เฉยๆเนี่ยแมว
เบื่อไม่สนุกละแต่ถ้าเมื่อไหร่มันวิ่ง
เนี่ยโอ้โหมันหนีมันไม่เคยหนีแมวพ้นแมวก็
จะจับมันได้อีกแล้วก็มาตบมันเขี่ยมันอ่า
หนูบางตัวก็เลยแบบแกล้งตาย
ดูในคลิปวีดีโอแล้วก็ตลกดีนะแล้วพอแมว
เผลอมันก็แอบๆๆ
แล้วก็แอบตายต่อ
เพราะแมวเผลอหันไปที่อื่นปุ๊บ
แมวหายไปไหนแล้วเนี่ยเมื่อกี้ยังนอนหงาย
อยู่
เนี่ยแหละที่ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยกลัวมากเพราะว่า
ไปเอาหนูข้างนอกบ้านมาแล้วมาในบ้านมาเล่น
ในบ้านแล้วก็ถ้าเอ่อมันแกล้งตายเนี่ยแมว
ไม่สนใจเดี๋ยวหนูมันก็อยู่ในบ้านไง
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
อันนี้เป็นเรื่องของนิสัยแมวที่ชอบแบบชอบ
จับเหยื่อนะเราเรียกว่าตัวที่มันคอยหนี
แล้วมันก็จะมาเมื่อก่อนมันอาจจะจับมาแล้ว
กินนะเดี๋ยวนี้มันอิ่มแล้วไงมันมีอาหาร
กินใช่เพราะว่าที่บ้านก็มีอาหารเพราะว่า
บ้านครูปุ๊กเนี่ยจะใส่อาหารไว้ให้ตลอด
เวลา
ไม่มี 24 ชั่วโมง
ใช่หิวเมื่อไหร่ก็ได้ใช่เหมือนเซเว่น
อีเลฟเว่นค่ะ
แนวบอกมิน่าล่ะเขาบอกว่าแมวประเทศไทย
เนี่ย
อ้วน
อันนี้
ก็คิดเองเหมือนกันไง
เราก็ยังอยากกินเวลาไม่เหมือนกันเลย
ไม่ต้องกินข้าวตรงเวลาก็ได้ไงบลูชิหิวตอน
ไหนก็ไปกินตอนนั้นอย่างนี้ไงก็เลยคิดว่า
เออแมวก็คงเหมือนเราเนาะบางวันมันก็นอน
กลางวันบางทีก็นอนตอนเย็นบางทีก็นอนตอน
กลางคืนมันก็อาจจะหิวเวลาไม่ตรงไง
ครูปุ๊กรีบคิดเองอีกแล้ว
คิดเหมือนๆ
เหมือนๆเรา
เอาตัวเองไปเป็นแมว
เปลี่ยนกันเอ้าแมวต้องคิดเหมือนเราแน่ๆ
มีนิสัยอีกอย่างนึงค่ะที่คนเลี้ยงแมวอาจ
จะไม่ชอบค่ะก็คือแมวมันชอบควรโซฟาชอบ
ตะกุยอะไรแบบโอ้โห
ขาดหมดค่ะ
แนวคิดกูก็เป็นไหมคะเป็นค่ะโซฟามีกี่ตัว
ก็ตะกุยหมดเลยค่ะมันจะรับเล็บค่ะน้ำมี
เล็บแล้วมันก็จะไป
แล้ว
ชอบมากเลยที่โซฟาที่ประตูค่ะประตูใช่ไหม
ประตูเราจะมีประตูที่ปิดสำหรับกันแมลงกัน
ยุง
นะ
คะ
ใช่
ก็มันก็จะไปข่วนนะคะเวลาเขาจะออกจากออก
จากบ้านเนี่ย
นะเขาอยากออกไปข้างนอกเนี่ยเขาจะไปป่วน
อยู่ที่ประตูให้เราได้ยินแกว่งๆๆๆไง
ก็ต้องไปเปิดประตูให้
นะอ๋อเขาอยากออกใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่ว่าแบบเขา
ไปรับ
ถ้าเล็บ
ข่วนที่ประตูเนี่ยไม่ได้รับเล็บค่ะอยาก
ออกข้างนอกแต่ถ้าคนที่โซฟาเนี่ยรับเล็บ
หรือบางทีเนี่ยลูกลูกเอากระเป๋ากระเป๋า
เป้นะ
วางไว้เนี่ย
นะถ้าวางไว้ที่พื้นเมื่อไหร่เนี่ยเดี๋ยว
เขามาเขาก็ขึ้นไปบนกระเป๋าแล้ว
ชอบๆชอบ
นะลูกสาวก็เลยไปซื้อที่
รับเล็บแมวอ่ะมันจะเป็นเหมือนลังกระดาษ
อ่ะเหมือนๆเหมือนกล่องกระดาษใช่ไหมซูชิ
ที่มันจะหนาๆเหมือนกล่องกระดาษแบบนี้ค่ะ
ใช่ค่ะคล้ายๆอย่างนั้น
แต่ของครูปุ๊กเนี่ยมันไม่ได้เป็นตาข่าย
แบบอย่างอันนี้อันนี้เป็นกระดาษลูกฟูกค่ะ
ใช่
ช้อนๆกันเห็นมั้ยเนี่ยใช่ๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆ
แต่ว่า
ของอันเนี้ยมันมีสโลปใช่มั้ยแต่ว่าของครู
ปุ๊กเนี่ยมันจะเป็นแบบสี่เหลี่ยมธรรมดา
ค่ะแล้วก็วางไว้ตรงใกล้ๆตู้เย็นตรงใกล้ๆ
ที่ๆเขาจะเดินประตูอะไรอย่างเงี้ยสำหรับ
วางไว้ใกล้ๆนะให้โซฟา
บางคนแบบทำแบบนี้ค่ะแล้วก็ปูทับโซฟาอีกที
เป็นแบบเหมือนแบบเป็นที่คุมโซฟาเพราะว่า
ยังไงยังไงเนี่ยทำเอาอันนี้มาให้ก็ยังไป
โซฟาอยู่ค่ะใช่ค่ะถูกต้องค่ะนะเพราะว่า
เป็นนิสัยเขาเนอะชอบเล่นชอบสนุกชอบวิ่ง
แล้วก็ไปฝนเล็บข่วนรับเล็บค่ะ
นะแล้วถ้าเกิดเอาเขาไปแล้วไปตัดเล็บ
ก็ยังรับอยู่เหมือนกันใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะมัน
เป็นมันเป็นธรรมชาติของแมวนะว่าแมวแมว
เนี่ยจะต้องรับเล็บตัวเองให้มันแหลมให้คม
ตลอดเวลาเพราะว่าเวลาเขาไปล่าเหยื่อที่
คือชีพบอกเหยื่อเค้าก็คือหนูนกจุกอะไรแบบ
เนี้ยเค้าจะได้มีกรงเล็บที่ไปตะปบอืมจิก
เอาไว้นะฮะแล้วก็หนูนะหรือนกหรือจิ้งจก
เนี่ยที่เดินๆเนี่ยมัน
ก็จะไปจับได้ไงดูซิ
อือ
นะเขาก็เลยรับเล็บเขาตลอดเวลาค่ะ
ทีนี้เขาบอกว่าบางทีเนี่ย
เราอาจจะเข้าใจผิดบางเรื่องเกี่ยวกับแมว
ถ้าเกิดแมวเดินมาหาเราใช่ไหมแล้วแมวก็นอน
หงายอย่างนี้จริงๆก็บอกท้องแมวเนี่ยแมว
ไม่ชอบให้จับนะจับของแล้ว
มันจะแบบหงุดหงิดมันไม่ชอบให้จับท้องแต่
ถ้าคางเนี่ยใช่ไหมทางเนี่ยโอเคมันชอบใช่
ไหมใช่
มันไม่ชอบให้จับท้องเพราะว่ามันกลัว
กลัวว่าเพราะว่ามันเป็นส่วนที่นิ่มที่สุด
ใช่ไหมนิ่มที่สุดเพราะไม่มีขนไม่มีขนแมว
บังไว้ไงมันก็จะแบบไม่อยากให้ใครมายุ่ง
กับท้องมัน
แล้วเวลาที่โดนท้องมันมันจะรู้สึกเสียว
แบบจะรู้สึกคือมันรับรู้มากอ่ะเหมือนแบบ
ผิวหนังอ่ะตรงเนี้ยไม่ค่อยรู้สึก
แต่พอแบบตรงนี้บางทีตรงที่แบบเรารู้สึก
มันบางๆอ่ะพอแตะแล้วอึ้ยแบบมันจะรู้สึก
แมวก็มีส่วนท้องที่มันรู้สึกแบบเป็นผิว
หนังที่แบบพอโดนแล้วแบบมันจะรู้สึกมันจะ
รู้สึกมากมีมีปฏิกิริยามีมีครบปุ๊บมันก็
กระเด้งขึ้นมาทันทีเลยใช่โดยเฉพาะถ้าแมว
ที่เราไม่ได้เลี้ยงนะนักเรียนต้องระวัง
ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยมีประสบการณ์ตอนเด็กๆค่ะเด็ก
ไม่รู้เห็นแมวไปร้านขนมไงไปซื้อขนมแล้ว
แมวนอนอยู่ก็เลยไปเล่นมันกำลังนอนแบบก็ไป
จับพุงพอจับพุงเท่านั้นแหละ
ที่ตรงข้อศอกเนี่ยแหละค่ะงับเลยค่ะ
เป็นรูเลย
คือมันไม่เหมือนหมานะโอเคเกาพุงได้ใช่ไหม
คุณเกาผมได้แต่แมวเนี่ยอันนั้นน่ะเป็นจุด
ที่มันรู้สึกเยอะมันจะมีมันจะมันมันจะไม่
ชอบอ่าทีเนี้ยบางทีมันเดินๆมาแล้วก็มานอน
หงายปึ๊บให้เราเนี่ยเราก็คิดอ้าวเกาพุง
เหรอมันไม่ชอบให้เกาพุงอ่ะนะเกาคางเนี่ย
โอเค
เข้ามานอนหงายเนี่ยเพราะอะไร
เพราะว่าเขารู้สึกสบายใจปลอดภัยเขาก็เลย
จะแบบนอนเพราะว่าแมวบ้านกรุ๊ปเนี่ยบางที
เขานอนหลับแล้วพอเขาแบบเปลี่ยนผ้าเนี่ย
เขาก็จะพลิกตัวเองหงายท้องแบบนอนแบบสบาย
ใจ
ก็แสดงว่าเขารู้สึกว่าเขาปลอดภัยอืมเขา
ถึงทำแบบนั้นถูกไหมใช่
อันนี้ก็ต้องเข้าใจแมวไม่ใช่แมวนอนหงาย
ปุ๊บอ๋ออยากเกาท้องเลย
[ปรบมือ]
ค่ะบางทีเนี่ยนะ
แต่ไม่ใช่ที่บ้านนะ
อันนั้นก็แสดงว่าไม่เข้าใจแมวนะ
เด็กๆไงตอนเด็กๆ
นะ
เขาบอกว่าแมวเนี่ยชอบอะไรที่เป็นของส่วน
ตัว
ไม่ชอบแบ่งคนอื่น
ถ้ามีบ้านคือถ้าเป็นหมาเนี่ยมีบ้านหมา
บ้านหมาหมาตัวที่ 1 ตัวที่ 2 ตัวที่ 3 มา
ใช้ด้วยกันได้แต่ถ้าเป็นแมวเนี่ยเหมือน
กับมันไม่ชอบนะเวลามีกลิ่นของแมวตัวอื่น
แล้วเขาก็จะเลือกมีที่นอนประจำของเขานะ
บางทีเนี่ยครูปุ๊กเนี่ยมีผ้านิ่มๆเนาะ
มีภาพแบบผ้านิ่มๆแล้วก็ปูให้สำหรับนอนไม่
นอนค่ะ
อืม
บางทีเนี่ยจะปีนขึ้นไปแล้วก็นอนอยู่บนตู้
เขาจะรู้สึกว่าข้างบนเนี่ยปลอดภัยเพราะ
ว่าอย่างที่ครูปุ๊กบอกว่าบ้านครูปุ๊ก
เนี่ยมีแมว 3 ตัวเพราะฉะนั้นตัวนึงเนี่ย
มันก็มีความกลัวก็เลยขึ้นไปอยู่ข้างบน
แล้วก็จะเป็นนอนเป็นที่ประจำค่ะนะก็นอน
อยู่ข้างบนตู้เขาจะรู้สึกสบายใจแล้วก็นอน
แบบสบายบางทีก็นอนหงายบางทีครูมันจะตกลง
มาค่ะแต่มันก็ไม่ตกนะ
แมวตกอย่างที่สูงไม่เป็นไรค่ะมันไม่หงาย
ท้องมันก็จะหมุนตัว
ยิมนาสติก
นอนอยู่ใต้โต๊ะ
คือทำที่นอนให้ตรงอื่นก็ไม่นอนก็นอนอยู่
ใต้โต๊ะเนี่ยเขาก็จะนอนของเขาประจำอย่าไป
ยุ่งกับเขานะเพราะว่าครูก็เคยไปจัดเป็น
แบบทำที่นอนให้อะไรอย่างเงี้ยเปลี่ยนเลย
ค่ะนอนตรงนี้นะเออแบบนี้แหละนะก็ไปทำให้
นะเห็นคันๆนอนใต้โต๊ะใช่ไหมโอเคไปปูให้มี
ที่นอนนิ่งๆ
เปลี่ยนที่เลยค่ะไม่นอน
อย่ามายุ่งกับฉันอย่ามาวุ่นวายกับฉันนะฮะ
ส่วนอีกตัวนึงเนี่ยก็ชอบนอนอยู่กับคนค่ะ
เมื่อไหร่นอนปุ๊บเนี่ยนะใครมีแบบห่มผ้า
ปุ๊บเนี่ยตรงขาเราจะแยกออกใช่ไหมเขาก็จะ
มานอนอยู่ระหว่างตรงขาตรงกลางเนี่ยเขาจะ
ชอบมาก
แต่ละตัวนะก็จะชอบแบบไม่เหมือนกันจะ
ป้วนเปี้ยนอยู่บางทีก็ไม่ได้ไม่ได้อยาก
ให้แบบมาให้คนมากอดหรืออะไรแต่อยากอยู่
ใกล้ๆเพื่อความสบายใจมันนั่งอยู่ใกล้ๆพอ
แล้ว
ครูก็คิดว่าเขารู้สึกว่าเขาอยู่กับคน
เนี่ยคนดูแลเขาได้เขาจะปลอดภัยเหมือนเป็น
บอดี้การ์ดเขาก็เลยมาอยู่ใกล้ๆนึกออกไหม
แต่ไม่ได้แบบไม่ได้อยากให้เราไปวุ่นวาย
กับเขาหรืออะไรอย่างนี้เขาก็จะมานอนเฉยๆ
นะแต่ว่ารู้สึกว่าถ้าเอ่อเดินไปไกลจากเรา
เนี่ยเวลาเขาไปเจอแมวตัวอื่นแล้วเขาโดน
กัดหรืออะไรอย่างเงี้ยเค้าจะแบบยิ่งกลัว
ก็จะแบบมันอยู่กับคนเวลามีแมวมาเราก็จะ
เป็นคนไล่แมวให้ใช่ไหม
เขาก็จะรู้สึกปลอดภัยว่าเราเหมือน
บอดี้การ์ดอันนี้เราเป็นทาสแมวใช่ไหมคะ
ก็มีคนพูดแบบนั้นค่ะเวลาใครที่รักแมวมากๆ
แล้วดูแลเอาใจใส่แมวต้องแมวหนาวไหมแมวกิน
อาหารหรือยังแมวต้องมีชุดแบบนี้แมวต้องทำ
แบบนี้อะไรอย่างเงี้ยอันนี้พลาดค่ะ
พลาดก็เหมือนคนรับใช้ใช่ไหมเหมือนทำทุก
อย่างให้อาบน้ำเป่าขนหาอาหารให้กินถึง
เวลาอาจจะแบบมีเล่นด้วยเพื่อให้ออกกำลัง
กายนะอันนี้ไม่ตะกุยตะกุยเสร็จแล้วเนี่ย
ไม่ดีแล้วซื้อใหม่ก็ต้องเอามาให้หาของ
เล่นมาให้โห่อันนี้ล่ะค่ะครูปุ๊กคิดว่า
เราเนี่ยเป็นทาสตอนแรกเราก็คิดว่าอ๋อเรา
เป็นเจ้าของเราเป็นบอส
แต่ไม่แมวเป็นบอส
มึงอยากจะกินอย่างอื่นวันนี้เอาอาหารให้
เอ้าวันนี้ทำไมไม่กินน่ะเนี่ย
อยากเปลี่ยน
เราก็ต้องหามาเปลี่ยนใช่ไหม
เราก็จะหาให้
แล้วก็มาลองดูอันนี้กินไหมคะอันนี้แล้ว
ชอบไหม
หรือว่าบางทีแมวก็ชอบกินปลาค่ะ
ปลาทูน่า
อันนี้อร่อย
เจ้าของยังกินแค่ปลาทู
ตัวละ 30 บาท 40 บาทแมวกินปลาทูน่า
กระป๋องละ 50 บาท
มีไม่ถึงตัว
เราด้วยความรักไงนะ
โดยที่บางทีเขาก็ไม่ได้ร้องขอค่ะเขาก็ไม่
ได้แบบพี่ช่วยฉันหน่อยเอ่อฉันอยากได้อัน
นี้ฉันอยากได้อันนี้ก็ไม่ค่ะนะแต่เราคิด
ให้เองไง
แล้วนักเรียนล่ะคะมีใครเนี่ยเป็นทาสแมว
หรือเปล่าตอนเนี้ยครูปุ๊กคนนึงแล้วค่ะ
เป็นทาสแมว
ครูปุ๊กคิดว่าต้องมีนักเรียนที่เป็น
เหมือนครูปุ๊กแน่ๆเลยค่ะ
ก็วันนี้นะเราคุยว่าเราเนี่ยเข้าใจแมวใน
ลักษณะที่โดยคิดแบบเปรียบเทียบกับตัวเรา
ชอบไม่ชอบเพราะว่าเราเป็นทาสเขา
รักเขามากใช่ค่ะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยนักเรียน
ใครเป็นเหมือนครูปุ๊กคอมเมนต์มาหน่อยนะคะ
เหมือนกัน
เป็นทาสแมวเหมือนกันวันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วนะ
คะ
ขอบคุณครูปุ๊กแล้วก็ขอบคุณนักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะสวัสดี
ทุกๆคนค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ